so on Tuesday evening I was nearly
arrested by security at DePaul
University my crime I set foot on campus
on Wednesday evening protesters tried to
shut down a lecture I was giving at
University of Wisconsin in Madison and
police officers were told
stand down by the administration now the
problem on America's college campuses is
not just the snowflake college students
since the 1960's that have always been
lots of young people insistent on
quashing free speech and destroying
campus freedom but just as in the 1960s
it actually takes cowardly
administrators to make a leftist fascist
dream come true that was the story to
Paul months ago the alt-right
popularized Milo
visited T'Pol where protesters greeted
him by taking over the stage and
screaming at him and threatening
violence and secure it into anything the
administration responded by banning both
the Annapolis and me they added me
because students at Cal State Los
Angeles had nearly rioted when I visited
this week I showed up it's a call at the
invitation of the young America's
Foundation group on campus the
administration made clear that they'd
shut down the events if I was speaker so
the group attempted to register me as a
guest administration block dad so he
attempted to register me as a member of
fellow speaker for steno hoff sommers
esteem the administration blocked at
2:00 in an unprecedented move expecting
my arrival they mandated that everybody
wears special wristbands and be screened
by metal detectors they could ensure
that I didn't end up in the hall when I
showed up I was confronted by about 30
security guards from the university
there were five or six local cops
presence as well as well as the sheriff
of Cook County to facilitate an arrest
if security decided to move on me and
they did openly threatened me with the
rest if I attempted to attend Kristina's
lecture you can see the video it's a Lee
Weyer calm here's the amazing thing
there were no protesters none not a
single one but the administration was so
intent on clay cating protesters who
didn't even show up they banned me
personally from entering a campus to
give a speech on free speech by the way
that was just the beginning
last night at u-dub Madison student
protesters stood up every few minutes
and began screaming
safety and shame to disrupt I'll show
you the video in just a few minutes
they'd been planning it for days they
even had a secret Facebook group titled
F white supremacy interrupting Ben
Shapiro
why didn't security clear them out even
when they march down to the front of the
stake and attempted to block me
physically from the audience
well because the administration had told
university police not to remove the
protesters at all and if they had
removed the protesters they should shut
down the entire event getting this so if
the protesters disturb things the police
can't remove them and if they do remove
them that remove everybody that means 20
protesters could simply stick around and
by doing so prevent 450 people who'd
spent all day waiting from hearing a
lecture on free speech as u-dub student
jordan zadra said this mentality gives
protesters a license to shut down any
speech they don't like this is the
rioters veto and it only exists that
thanks to the cowardice of
administrators i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show and we opened of
course by saying hello to our
advertisers over at texture calm texture
calm slash bend so if you're somebody
who wants to binge read write you're not
just a binge watcher like Netflix or
binge eater you're a binge reader you
just need to read all the time but you
don't really want to buy separate
subscriptions to a thousand different
newspapers and magazines you need
texture calm texture calm is fantastic
it is an app and and once you get a
texture it allows you to get articles
and backlogs from the world's most
popular magazines at anytime anywhere
using your smartphone or your tablet and
right now you get a free trial right now
when you get a texture calm / pen you
get immediate entry to all of the top
magazines you get the back issues get
bonus video contest you start reading
binge reading right now free when
texture comes like I love it I use it
myself I am as you know one of the
world's most prolific readers and so
texture Kron has made it significantly
more easy for me to get all the articles
that I want to read from great magazines
and the list of magazines is virtually
endless I mean it's all my sports
magazines so my news magazines I mean
it's everything from Sports Illustrated
I don't have to even subscribe to Sports
Illustrated anymore I just go to texture
and I can get access to their articles
to to get to other magazines like that
some of the some of the news magazines
like Time The New Yorker which is fun to
read for for kicks and giggles if you're
if you are a very conservative but
texture calm is the name of the app and
you go to texture calm / been to get
that free trial right now check it out
see if you like it and then if you like
it keep it so here we go all right lots
to get to so we start with my experience
is a university
Wisconsin last night in Madison and it
is it was pretty amazing so after DePaul
tried to arrest me
DePaul also you know threatened to shut
down the entire event so I went in so I
went over to University of Wisconsin at
Madison and while I was at University of
Wisconsin at Madison we found out hours
in advance that were gonna be a bunch of
protest groups the rumor was there were
gonna be two black lives matter groups
and there was also going to be a white
supremacist group which has been about
the state of my ear and so they told us
all this and they told us they were only
assigning three cops right three cops
for like 500 people and a bunch of
protesters if this sounds like a bad
idea that's because it is a terrible
idea
it's truly an awful idea and it was
designed to be an awful idea as I say
the administration told the cops to
stand back and let all of this happen
and they said that if I said that people
had to be moved out or if there was an
attempt to make an arrest
they would have to actually shut down
the entire Benton em to the hall so we
got rid of four hundred and fifty people
because twenty people decided to disrupt
well things didn't go precisely how the
protesters wanted they started standing
up and shouting interrupting they would
walk down to the front of the stage but
but the crowd was not having any of it
and neither was I here is a montage of
some of the better moments in last
night's lecture a University of
Wisconsin Madison it's time the folks in
case you hadn't noticed that the folks
with the swastikas aren't too nice to my
type and by the way I'm fully aware of
this private Facebook page titled F
white supremacy interrupting Ben Shapiro
well
with all due respect a few right back
gang
it's like it's like Game of Thrones
should I get undressed and walk down
decency decency decency decent okay so
as good times you can see all around
eventually they left the double flip off
was in response to the fact that all of
the protesters as they were leaving or
shouting F white supremacy and flipping
off everybody in the hall including me
so it was it was just a joy I I did
enjoy the students there are fantastic
they're really good nature and it does
tell you something about why the Trump
phenomenon happened it really does what
it tells you is that people don't care
about the response nearly as much as
they care about the fact that the West
can't control itself left simply cannot
control - they're out of their minds and
because of that people have reacted to
that by saying screw all you people
we're not gonna do anything you want
even if somebody is bad person like
Trump was during the primaries in the
general even if someone says ridiculous
things you don't have the right to stand
on ceremony since you've been saying
this stuff about everybody including
Mitt Romney so you keep saying to us fu
your white supremacist well F you all
and we'll elect Trump just to show you
now do I think that's the best response
no I don't but I do think that it's a
justifiable and under well
understandable is better work an
understandable response by people and I
have that same response I do I have the
same feeling of you guys can't control
yourselves you can't engage in in the
nature of Western civilization you can't
do any of it and then you turn around
and you blame us when things go wrong
even though you can all go to hell now
that was sort of the feeling last night
there was a real feeling of brotherhood
inside the room between all of the
people who stayed and toughed it out
it's like a 25 minute thing I mean they
they shut it down they were yelling they
were screaming they're shouting shame
they're also shouting safety at one
point when they're chanting safety I
said a couple things they chanted safety
and I said and number one you are safe
you're all making trouble right now
nobody's punching you that's America
it's great and then they continue to
shout safety at which point I just said
I don't understand who farted but in any
case you can see why this drove the
Trump movement can see why it drove the
right to victory in this election and
you can see why if the left keeps
playing this game they're playing with
fire politically Kellyanne Conway I
think actually summed it up pretty well
she the spokesperson obviously for the
from
here's what she had to say but you know
we're just treating these they were
treating these adolescents and these
Millennials like precious snowflakes I'm
just amazed how many texts and emails
I'm receiving is one person of all these
professors saying you don't have to take
the test you can get college credit if
you protest what's the worst thing that
can happen in these Millennials that
Donald Trump will make good on this
promise to create 25 million new jobs
that he'll and leash energy investment
that he'll get rid of the Obamacare
penalty on day one so that you're not
forced to buy a government-run health
care okay so look I think that she's
exaggerating the case for all the things
that Trump's gonna do for Millennials
but and and I understand why Millennials
don't like Trump you know they don't
like the language that he uses or the
things recent but the precious snowflake
idea we're just gonna shut it down we
can't go to class we can't participate
in normal society we can't actually take
tests we have to get out of essays all
this is a bunch of crap and people react
to it as you would expect them to which
is
grow up grow up get a life grow up stop
being such babies and that's totally
understandable
it really is Ted Cruz gets it right -
Cruz was on TV yesterday and he said
that all these protests against Donald
Trump they're showing that hypocrisy is
unranked display from the left we have
seen hypocrisy on ranked display from
the left all of the folks who jumped on
their high horse and we're lecturing to
president elect Trump you've got to
accept the results of the election look
look these are now the idiots that are
protesting in the street and laying
their bodies down in front of cars and
disrupting traffic and and that we had
an election the people spoke democracy
is a powerful powerful way of choosing
and you know I think Americans across
this country I think this is this is
across the line of Republicans of
Democrats of Independence of
libertarians I think Americans are
excited about the opportunity to have an
administration that actually protects
our rights that brings back jobs okay
and increases right that of course the
people did speak in these people are
making trouble it's just driving more
people into Trump's open arms I mean as
I said yesterday I really do not like
Steve banning him now and the
defending Steve Bannon because the media
overreach I who did not vote for Donald
Trump them in a position of rooting hard
for dominant Trump to stop these kinds
of people because come on this is
ridiculous this is ridiculous you shut
down traffic you act like babies and
last night I actually let off the speech
by saying I brought a diaper and some
safety pins I said you guys want to wear
safety pins I brought something that you
can use also and it's a diaper and I
said you know the first thing is if you
want to have a discussion let's have a
discussion if you want to act like
babies please leave I said don't act
like babies and the first thing they do
is they start interrupting and shouting
like my two-year-old all of this is
deeply frustrating all of it is deeply
upsetting the faculty administration
goes along with it is also even more
upsetting these are people in position
of power we should know better the rest
of the state of Wisconsin looks at
Madison and they say you people are out
of your minds no wonder we're gonna vote
for Donald Trump and it's the entire
left now the entire left has reacted to
Trump with such insanity and I think
they probably would have reacted about
70 percent the same it could have been
somebody like Cruz or Rubio but the fact
that they're reacting the way they are
to Trump it actually is just making
people more likely to ignore them then
since a fox the former presidents of
Mexico yeah just a few months ago he was
he was cursing at Trump he's not gonna
build we're not gonna build your effing
wall and now he's calling Trump
illegitimate do you think that drives
Americans into or away from the arms of
Donald Trump how could people in power
in Mexico do business with him right now
I think he's an illegitimate president
of the United States
why is he illegitimate he just won an
election but he would have to legitimize
he didn't won the general election so
he's got too many people against him and
they have shown out on the streets but
anyway in Mexico we are also we can be
rude also as I said we're strong now
we're going to defend our people
wherever they are in Mexico or outside
of Mexico in the United States we are
not gonna let this guy to offend them
anymore to offend the dignity and more
so to deny the enormous contribution
they make the US economy okay so you've
been sent a fax saying we're gonna stand
up for all the illegal immigrants
and we're going to stand up against
Donald Trump Americans go why do we want
to hear from the former presidents of
Mexico about why you're gonna stand up
for your legal immigrants in the United
States when Mexico is making a lot of
money off of remittances from illegal
citizens living in the United States why
is that a good thing by the way it's
also funny to watch been sent a fox
pretend it it sounds from Piz is the
only Bulgarian then literally right
behind him he supported the ping sent a
fox and his wife I have never actually
been in a place where I wanted something
to paint my portrait but if I did I
probably wouldn't hang it behind me
during interviews it seems kind of who
here meanwhile the Democrats continue to
demonstrate their hypocrisy on every
level Josh earnest over at the White
House he's already ripping into Trump
he's saying that the Trump is
undermining our NATO alliances now
there's 3 - this means an alum spends a
lot of the primaries talking about a
NATO the members of NATO weren't paying
up and that we would abandon them if
they didn't pay their fair share what
people are forgetting by the way is that
when you say two countries not just in
NATO but but across the world but if you
guys don't pass more money then we're
going to abandon you China is willing to
pay them that money in in Southeast Asia
in order to make them allies right
Russia is willing to bribe countries in
order to exert influence we're not the
only players in this game it's not just
a matter of you passed money or well
abandon you there are other players
we're going to seek to fill that back in
but Josh earnest says that supporting
our NATO allies is a long-standing
tradition we just can't believe the
trunklid name President Obama has made
the case for is the long-standing strong
bipartisan tradition of strong relations
between the United States and our NATO
allies and President Obama certainly
dedicated a significant portion of his
presidency to making sure that that
relationship was deepened that that
relationship was strengthened in a way
that had enormous and significant
national security and economic benefits
for the American people and there
certainly is a tradition of presidents
of both parties choosing to pursue that
but ultimately president likes Trump
will have to determine what sort of path
he wants to chart from here okay and of
course that's not even true I mean Obama
has under my nail routinely he didn't do
anything when Ukraine was invaded by
Russia into anything to defend the
Baltic States when Putin is threatening
no he removed the missile defense system
from from
even though they were asking for it you
moved it from Czech Republic even though
they were asking for it the idea that
food that Obama has stood up for NATO
that he some sort of hot gun foreign
policy is just laughable today Obama's
overseas meeting with Angela Merkel and
he was spending time talking about how
something needs to stand up to Russia
from the guy who's been bending over
backwards for Russia from the guy who
drew a red line would commit the Syrians
and then backed off of it and let Russia
take over the place from the guy who's
let Russia again and take over Crimea
from the guy who's allowed flat Amir who
become a world figure again right that
guy is lecturing Trump and so normal
people look at this and they say you
don't get to lecture anybody go screw
yourself yeah I really think that could
be bit Trump is and we'll see what he
becomes but but for now what Trump is is
he giant pulsating bigoted middle finger
right at the left right at the heart of
the left and they deserve it they do
deserve it there is justice for the left
in the fact that Donald Trump as
president does that mean that he's gonna
be wonderful I don't know yeah I don't
think so that's why I didn't vote for
him but we'll find out we'll find out in
January we get to some of these cabinet
picks and what he's doing right now some
which is very clever we'll talk about
that in just a few minutes but the left
continues to just make mockery of
themselves like here's the ACLU director
and he says that opposing Donald Trump
is going to be at the ACLU is all about
like he's gonna try and he might get
part of the way through and they will
definitely clone back let's take the ban
on immigrants or the deportation of
immigrants 11 million people he wants to
deport on Sunday 60 minutes he said he
wants a focus and 2 to 3 million of the
immigrants who broke the law immediately
yeah how's he gonna find them the
criminals are not just lined up in some
database who happened to be immigrants
he's gonna have to comb through
immigrant communities how's he gonna
have to do that through that dragnet
searches through unlawful searches and
seizures do you think the Department of
Homeland Security is going to say oh you
undocumented immigrant let me see if
you're a criminal
oh no criminal walk free do you think
they're gonna let the undocumented
immigrants who don't have a criminal
records just slip away we're in for the
fight of our lives and when the
president-elect said on Sunday they he's
super and tried to pour two to three
million people he's talking dragnet
unconstitutional searches and seizures
that will violate the Fourth Amendment
the Fifth Amendment the 14th amendment
and what's gonna be so intense for us is
that we have to document those cases
this is not something you can bring a
class-action lawsuit on behalf of all
the undocumented immigrants you have to
go and show the cases the fact patterns
talk to the clients depose people make
sure you have the all the important work
and we go into the nest over there a
lecture about legality the ACL u--'s a
hypocritical organization has spent the
entire Obama administration doing
nothing about Obama's violation of civil
liberties everything from the IRS
targeting conservatives to the DOJ
targeting The Associated Press and the
ACLU had virtually nothing to say about
any of this Trump has not talked about
dragnets
at least not in a while when Turner says
he wants to deport criminal illegal
immigrants he's talking about the same
people Obama says he wants to deport I
didn't see the ACLU talking about how
Obama couldn't support criminals because
he'd have to impose a dragnet like
they're reading into Trump something
that he never said but again it's all
hypocrisy it's all over the top it's all
the left cannot just deal with the fact
there are things they don't like about
Trump he has to be turned ADA super
Hitler who's gonna send his SS goon
squads into legal immigrant communities
and start rounding people off but my
gamble is actually my bet is that yeah
she doesn't do any of that stuff
then when all is said and done Donald
Trump ends have been posing pretty much
the plan that Jeb Bush wanted to impose
which was shut the border figure out
what to do the people here I think
that's pretty much what Trump will look
like I don't think we're talking mass
deportations I think that was all for
show I don't think it we'll see what
happens but the ACLU is certainly
jumping the gun on all of this stuff now
the media still can't deal with the fact
that Donald Trump won and so they're
just making fools of themselves we'll
get to all of that in just a minute but
first we have to say hello to a new
advertiser they spoke weekly with some
of the founders of this company it's
called legacy box legacy boxes fantastic
okay so if you're somebody who has a
bunch of old video a lot of video tapes
like VHS recordings we have old film
reels or even if you have DVDs and you
want to compile all your old memories
onto a memory strick on a memory drive
but particularly get the VHS of DVDs if
pictures that you wanna convert it over
to digital very time-consuming very
expensive my family just did it with
some of my childhood videos and it was
very very pricey legacy box helps make
this happen for you in a quick
affordable and convenient way so here's
how it works you take the legacy box
maybe you get in contacts then at legacy
box com a slash bet and they send you a
box and you put in all your old tapes
your film pictures audio recordings to
send them everything and then
get everything back in a couple of weeks
on DVD or on a thumb drive so instead of
you having to worry about there's fire
in the house grab all the memories
everything is on a thumb drive
everything is on a DVD for you it's
ready to watch it's ready to share it's
a beautiful thing to do for your parents
by the way it's a beautiful thing to do
for your grandparents and it's a great
thing to do to preserve all those
childhood memories the moths don't get
at them or so that age doesn't want the
film and destroy your childhood and
that's what legacy box is for they take
care of everything they put a they put a
barcode on every item so you can trace
where it is in the process of uploading
and editing and 250,000 families use
them it's a really great service I would
I trust them with with my memories I
think they're gonna be an amazing
company its legacy box comm slash Ben to
get a 40% discount on your order again
legacy box comm slash Ben 40% to spend
on your order perfect Christmas present
for mom and dad perfect Christmas
present for the rest of the family these
are things that you're gonna want to
keep forever and that means you have to
put them in a store bill place where
they're not going to degrade and where
you don't have to dig through boxes and
boxes it takes in order to get what you
want so everything gets a little
uploaded digitally great company great
idea I'm very very big into the idea you
want to preserve the family memories and
is a great way to do it it's legacy box
comm / Ben to get that 40% discount on
legacy box really first-rate company
couldn't be prouder to be advertising
with them